Well, for some areas it is uh part of it
of course because many people are
getting into these deep domains. You
know when big conferences for machine
learning you have uh 16,000 people
coming in very smart people like
yourself and uh coming in and developing
new solutions. The thing is that um some
of the culture of I mentioned earlier
this magic cycle and to me one of my uh
interests always was both on the
research side as well as the product
side right for over a decade I was
actually leading products in search at
Google. So what we see today is this
convergence that actually you use much
more you have this cycle where quite
often the same people who are developing
the new algorithms or the new techniques
for AI are the ones actually
implementing and working very closely
with the product teams to actually
implement them which is very exciting to
me.
[Music]
Hi everybody. H really good to be here.
Oded Nlesh Bat, thank you for inviting
us uh from across the sea. Wish we could
be there in person and I was really
excited when Od had this idea that we'll
do a talk together. Uh so uh Dad, I've
known you for all of 29 years. Great to
be here. By the way, the multigeneration
in this case actually Michael was first
in J venture and then he got me in. So
uh yeah, that's the order. That's very
true. H I met Oed my first day at
Stanford and uh since then I got to be a
part of J Ventures getting a chance to
work with amazing team getting chance to
join as an LP and and now uh really
proud to be a founder part of the J
ventures portfolio and we're going to
talk about um you know we're going to
use this excuse h to have this
multigenerational conversation h with AI
in the background. So everybody knows
that AI is transforming everything and
uh I think that this is going to be
really interesting because we're not
just going to look at the way AI is
transforming coding and the way that AI
is transforming you know the application
layer and the infrastructure layer but
dad you're you're in charge of of
research within Google and that holds I
think a special foundational piece as
part of what it means for us to develop
these a AI systems and looking into the
future and so I'd love to dive in and
and right before that I' I'd love to
understand a little bit from what what
does research mean? Uh because AI used
to be a research main task but now
everybody's using it but what is
research especially in the context of
AI.
Yeah. So uh so first this is really
exciting times and uh you know
reflecting back when I did my uh final
projects in in university this was about
machine learning and it was about how to
we have a software that can actually
learn on its own to play a game and uh
even then I was actually astounded that
in just a few days I managed to use some
techniques from the 50s or 60s uh and
already developed a game that could
actually you know win over me. But AI as
we know went into a winter for uh many
years what they call the AI winter
because expectations did not meet. But
what we happened in last uh decade more
than decade now is really this
transformative uh impact of AI that
everybody of course understands. Now
what is research? research really is
about how to find new solutions to
problems and um and and the way one
thing that I'm really excited about
research all my life you know uh from
early in my career I was uh uh thinking
about research about uh it has the
aspect of intellectual curiosity but
importantly it's driven by the kind of
questions that we want to solve now to
me research is about how to take the
state-of-the-art technologies that we
have they understand the problems that
need to be solved and then to push them
to the next level and um one thing that
I'm always been excited about is what I
call the magic cycle of research which
is to identify those important problems
to uh then have this u research
breakthroughs you know new solutions and
then to apply it back to real world kind
of solutions in a way this has been
always there in fact when I was early in
my career in Bellabs in the heyday of
Bellabs in a mathematical center this
was also something that I was excited
about except that then the magic cycle
used to take years quite often and and
by the way this has been always true if
you look into some of the mathematical
developments you know of the
mathematicians over they were motivated
by the kind of physics questions the
thing that we're seeing today is that
research is driving technology in a pace
that is unprecedented we see an
acceleration so research is about how to
solve the new technologies in AI in uh
now of course generative AI is the uh
the hot things or diffusion models, but
it's also about better algorithms,
optimizations. It's about computing
systems. It's about how to develop
quantum computing or how to develop
solutions for healthcare, for education,
for climate and many other problems. Uh
it's about all those problems that we
don't know yet how to solve in
technology wise and then translate them
into real technological solutions. And
so one of the areas that you're really
spending most of your time in is
societal impact. I think when I look
across the board, a lot of the things
that you're working on are things that
directly impact society at large,
whether it's saving people's lives
through health or whether it's looking
at the planet through climate
and and all the way down to things that
we don't even normally think about like
transportation, right? And so how is AI
and how is cutting edge research and AI
transforming these societal impact
landscapes, right? So of course now
research addresses all aspects of life
including products and businesses and
everything but one area that I'm really
passionate about is really how to use it
in order to unlock problems that are
impacting all of us. So healthcare is
one of those examples uh that are uh to
me where we're seeing a huge
transformation with AI and uh research
and um in a way this is obviously uh
something that can help save lives and
just to give you a few examples one of
the u problems that um you know one of
our legacy kind of u uh works on on our
teams at Google is on uh looking into AI
for screening for a condition called
diabetic retinopathy which can lead into
blindness if not treated.
uh if about about you know 400 million
people worldwide with diabetic are
actually at risk to get it. It's
relatively easily detectable by an
expert and then treatable. Problem is
there's a shortage of thousands of
experts around the world actually over
100,000 experts. Um so a landmark paper
from 2016 showed that actually AI can do
the work of um you know in in par with
an expert. And by the way, this is well
before a lot of the excitement recent
excitement of AI and a after a few years
actually we put it in the clinics and
now it's actually being used in India
and Thailand already had 700,000 people
screened to that. So it's practically
actually can save them from blindness
and now actually there are some um
strategic partnership that actually is
going to scale it to 6 million people.
Now that's an example for if I will uh a
legacy kind of technology. But now with
the new generative AI we see new
opportunities. For example, we took a
large language model and we looked into
the question can be adapted to
understand medical questions. And what
we could show is for the first time that
um it can actually answer US style
medical exam in a passing score which is
a big deal. By the time this was
published in nature, we already had a
system uh demonstration that we can
actually have it passed in 91%. And this
is something that can actually be used
in so many different systems and you
know already being tested by u various
healthcare providers such as HCA uh
because uh there are so many medical
applications where just the ability to
help out the doctors to help out the
experts can make a huge difference. And
what's what's different now? Because you
you so you've done research for decades
and you've been at the the cutting edge
of research for decades yet it feels
like things are shifting. It feels like
things are shifting at the the velocity
of research and the depth of the
research and the application and the
time to deployment and time to market
for researchdriven tasks. It's a great
question. So what we seeing today is
first the technologies
uh you know the development of cloud for
example cloud technology and open
sources and libraries is one of the
facilitators for that. Another one is
the so much talent goes now into into
research and development. And um and the
third one is also uh recognition by the
market that everybody needs to adopt
technologies and AI and then what you
see is so such demand actually people so
many are actually recognizing that they
need to test out these technologies.
This is true for every businesses and
for many aspects of life. Certainly in
healthcare we see that as as a big
shift. I saw a post recently by somebody
who said h soon every software engineer
will effectively be an ML engineer, an
AI engineer. What is the shift that
you're seeing on the engineering
landscape on the skills in this new
agentic era uh coming from the research
all the way to the application? Yeah. So
one of the fascinating aspects of using
uh AI for software engineering is the
fact that one it can be used as a tool
to empower software engineers and I'm
hearing from you know many developers
that actually it can make them much more
productive. Um on the other hand of
course there's an opportunity to
actually advance AI itself and machine
learning itself. So I would say that
every software engineer would need would
know how to use it for certain and many
are actually going to get into the
different layers of actually how to
advance it or how to uh develop more
aspects of that. But let me also point
out that one of the things I'm really
excited about is not only accelerating
solutions for uh areas that benefit from
science such as healthcare but actually
accelerate science itself. So think
about the future where actually uh every
researcher or every scientist can
actually get AI to help them in their
own research and accelerate that. In
fact, we did some step towards that. We
recently published a paper which we call
um uh kind of look into a research
system on which we call co-scientist
that helps out sift through literature
create help create a hypothesis in
response to a question posed by a
researcher. So the way I think about it
is think about a situation that if you
have a research lab, it's not only that
the head of the lab has assistants
working them, but actually every person
in the lab actually have AI to help them
accelerate their own research. And we
already got some examples that it could
accelerate some got some novel
hypothesis about treating some
conditions in the liver fibrosis or help
out identify some hypothesis about the
reason for some superbug uh which is
essentially um an infectious kind of uh
you know bacteria that that were the
researchers actually spent years to try
and identify what's the reason for that.
So to me this is one of the areas that
we are likely going to see an
acceleration which I think is quite
exciting. It seems to me also that one
of the things that are enabling that are
enabled now due to the usage and the and
the accessibility of AI is the shortage
of barrier to entry um to answer some of
those preliminary research questions to
even identify whether there's proof of
value in in in wanting to go deeper. So
the the barrier to entry and the
resources needed to answer those
fundamental research questions on okay
should I pursue this path or okay given
a 100 paths which of these should I
prioritize to pursue deeper given the
human talent which is now going to be
much more scarce than the agentic
talent. Do you also see that in your
line of work that the barrier to entry
is getting lower and lower for these
preliminary questions? Well for some
areas it is uh part of it of course
because many people are getting into
these deep domains. you know when big
conferences for machine learning you
have uh 16,000 people coming in very
smart people like yourself and uh coming
in and developing new solutions the
thing is that um some of the culture of
I mentioned earlier this magic cycle and
to me one of my uh interests always was
both on the research side as well as the
product side right for over a decade I
was actually leading products in search
at Google so what we see today is this
convergence that actually you use much
more you have a cycle where quite often
the same people who are developing the
new algorithms or the new techniques for
AI are the ones actually implementing
and working very closely with the
product teams to actually implement them
which is very exciting to me. I I think
it's incredible and I I'm I'm so excited
about everything that's happening with
AI. Uh we have a few minutes left and
you know I think that when we when I
reflect on AI and and I look at how how
exciting these developments are across
healthcare, societal impact uh and and
our own productivity in our own daily
lives uh it also has ramifications in in
how attackers and how malicious actors
are using them and my background is
coming from the cyber security and so I
think we'll flip seats for a second.
Well, let's go to the basics actually
because we're sitting now in your
amazing office here clarity and I
remember for years we've been discussing
during your journey and you were
developing hack generation Y and uh
having your startup as a teenager and
we're discussing where are you going to
start it and then at some point you
decided to actually pause actually
studies in Stanford and start clarity
why did you do that yeah you know I
think that um you know it was 2022 and I
was very fortunate to be spending time
with with Jay vent ventures and spending
time with innovation endeavors and and
looking at super evolution technologies
and where they're headed and and uh I
was very conveniently tasked with with
really diving into LLMs and generative
AI before it was coined generative AI
and was it was pretty incredible to me
to see how things are evolving on the
language front but very quickly also on
the visual and the voice front and the
auditory front. At the same time, I was
still at Stanford in, you know, in the
AI labs and the engineering and the
gates building and experimenting with
these tools and seeing the excitement
from all the engineers of what's
happening in the middle of the night
when people are developing and I brought
with me the background from from the
8200 unit.
So 5 years in cyber security before that
and I was really really interested in
thinking okay what is going to happen
when everybody will have access to these
tools to create hyperrealistic media at
scale in real time how many of our
systems are dependent on that in the
day-to-day our business operations and
our democracy in fact the company
effectively started in in the backyard
of of my one of my professors Larry
Diamond and and and looking at the
business impact but I said Okay. Wow. I
don't think businesses will be able to
continue operating the way that they do.
And and of course, this is just one
example of the way that AI is
transforming the attackers mindset from
fishing in this case, going from the uh
what used to be spray and prey, the
Nigerian prince SMS fish. Now all of a
sudden, it's hyperpersonalized, highly
targeted, realtime scenario, and using a
voice and a face that you might
recognize. So all of those things
together um I think led me to think okay
there's an emerging category
we'll have to figure out the right
business for it but this is going to be
really disruptive and and I want to be
where disruption is and I think that
technologically we can do some really
cool things here well I remember that
for at least few months you were kind of
explaining every in every conversation
you explain to people what's what's
going to be the problem and you were
telling hey there's going to be an
inflection point now couple years later
what What has changed? Where are we with
this deep fake and uh you know um yeah
there was a lot of market education
which is you know and I talked to a lot
of a lot of entrepreneurs um a lot of
them say you know run away from market
education yet and I think in cyber
security often you know you have to do
it if you want to be at the right
timing. Two years ago, I I I had, you
know, out of my 15 slide deck, I had
about eight slides about the problem,
you know, what are deep fakes? And over
time, I started getting feedback. Okay,
you can start removing these slides
because we get it. We're starting to
hear about it. And it started in because
it started happening in the news and
social media. And there was a big
tipping point in February of 2024 when
um a financial controller in England
went online in a Zoom call with their
CFO. There were four other people on the
call, all of them from the financial
team. And the financial controller was
instructed to transfer money to to to
another bank account in inst about 12
installments. Uh accumulating to $25
million. Uh of course with remote work,
the one was in Hong Kong, the other in
England, so they're not even in the same
location. The financial controller went
on to pursue the these transactions only
to discover a few hours later that he
sent them to a hacker's bank account and
it was a deep fake of a CFO and this
made tremendous headlines. Um it was a
month after we we raised our seed round
uh from uh from the funds and and it was
and it was a pivotal moment because I
think then people started understanding
okay AI is also starting to be used by
attackers in these ways and and so the
the market has shifted I think since
then we we've seen increased attacks and
and going back to what Orin just said in
his talk I I think that and and and that
the timing here is really important it's
really about hitting the timing of when
is it the when is the pain point enough
when do we see the value enough for the
companies and how do you operate really
responsibly and efficiently until that
happens and both developing the the
right technology uh we use you know AI
to fight AI it's been this way for the
last two years but also making sure that
we're at the edge you know once this
thing happens so that we can be with the
customers interesting but and and you're
sitting actually in this very uh
interesting or important and not that
common actually intersection of security
and cyber security and AI. What do you
see beyond the deep fake in terms of the
you know this intersection?
Yeah, the so I I'm really fortunate I
get to do now a a series here um with
Forbes on AI and security. I've gone
drawn extremely excited about the way
that AI is transforming cyber security.
H I'm actually really proud everything
that all the camera changes here. This
is all me playing here with butt inside
practicing my multitasking and it's it's
a really cool series because I get to
sit here with with other CEOs of other
startups and talking about how AI is
transforming the cyber security
landscape and it's transforming it in
every way. Um uh it's transforming it in
in cloud detection and response and
threat detection. It's transforming it
in in third party risk management. uh
it's transforming it in the way that
attackers are um are finding new ways
using these LLMs to identify zero day
vulnerabilities and endpoints and then
using a genic solutions to be able to
deploy those uh those malware and those
vulnerabilities at scale. And so we're
seeing increasing usage and lower
barrier of entry from the attackers in
fishing. Of course, the last teammate
report talked about a 2,000% increase in
fishing. Uh, and um, we're also seeing
it on the defensive side. So,
practically every cyber company is now
looking at how to use AI more
intelligently. I think it's not trivial
how to piece together the this AI and
cyber security because it's very, you
know, different domain expertise.
Practically every company I talk to now
has, you know, used LLMs in their in the
day-to-day and many are now figuring out
how do we piece together this domain
expertise to fine-tune these LLMs and go
beyond and how do we create these
agentic solutions and so we now see
incredible startups
I I saw just recently now a great one
that
well a couple great ones by by Guy
Fletcher and 7 AI and they were really
using aentic systems to empower the
security teams and so I I think that
what we're seeing in the cyber security
landscape as well in terms of AI is a
shift in responsibility from just
alerting and detection to now actual
remediation and prevention and how to
use agents to go and and work through
them which is which is really exciting.
Well, that's amazing. One one thing by
the way that reflects I I think your
kind of reflection here brings up is the
the pace of change. This goes back to
some of your earlier question. The pace
of change is unprecedented. And if you
think about where we've been just a
couple years ago and where we are today,
uh it's a good reminder to anybody who's
trying to predict what's going to be a
couple years from now. So this is one of
the things that I think is the most
exciting is this notion of uh very rapid
development, new opportunities and uh
and bigger opportunity to have impact on
on so many different levels. I I
completely agree. AI is accelerating
everything. Cyber security has always
been a game of cat and mouse. So in
nature it's always been how fast can you
go and can you go faster than than the
attacker. I I'm exhilarated by by this
arms race, right? and and you know
coming back I I was I was still in
Paloto when when I wanted to start the
company but I I really wanted to come
back and build the R&D center here in
Tel Aviv because I wanted that AI talent
that's coming from the IDF's mindset
from cyber security and and uh and the
lead combat of okay we wake up every day
having to reprove ourselves and so uh
with that I'm really want to thank you
Oded and Nlesh for uh for uh having us
here. Really really great. Appreciate
your time and thank you everybody for
listening. I hope it was interesting.
Yeah, you too. Have us here.